Speaker 1: Donald Trump was indicted. He will be
indicted. The jury voted to indict. He will be
arraigned on Tuesday within a couple hours. Donald
Trump's, I guess least favorite son, Eric Trump,
goes on Fox News and he reacts to the indictment
by ranting about CVS and Tylenol. Now, you might
be saying, David, wait, I know about Advil. I
know about Tylenol. What's Kyle Enol? I also don't
know. But here is Eric Trump ranting about CVS and
Tylenol. In response to his dad's indictment, it.
Speaker 2: Is every single day. And this is a
city I spent a lot of time in Europe that is
falling apart. I went into literally CVS the
other day, and you can't buy Tylenol because
it's locked behind these glass counters because
there's so much theft and there's so much looting,
there's so much homelessness and
crime. But yet their attention
is going after Donald Trump, little girl. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, listen, first of all, you go into
CVS or you go into Walgreens anywhere in this
country. When I was just recently in Florida,
I went in, I had to get my very powerful
hair product. It's locked up. I had to ask,
could you pretty pleased with the key? Open it up
for me. You go into a CVS north of New York City,
as I recently did, and the deodorant, my
girlfriend's deodorant. It's like, you know,
everything free. It's free of soy. It's free
of beef broth. There's no beef. It's, you know,
one of these hipster deodorants. It's locked up
somehow. I don't think that that's really the
alternative for Alvin Bragg to be focusing on
compared to the Trump indictment. What I would
suggest to Eric Trump is maybe hold off on these
pathetic appearances because you you really seem
unhinged and you literally went to CVS. What does
that mean as opposed to you sent someone? I don't
even know what this guy is talking about, locking
folks. Because what we are going to see over the
next let me think, 2448 So over the next 96 hours
leading up to the Trump arraignment is going to be
increasingly unhinged. And the hope is and I'm not
you know, people write in and say, David, you're
hoping that MAGA becomes violent. No, no, no, no,
no. I didn't want violence on January 6th. I'm
against violence. I don't want violence. I don't
want shootings. I don't want burning. I don't want
looting. I don't want any of it, no matter
who's doing it. I hope that MAGA doesn't get
violent over this. So far they really don't seem
to care. And even when Trump previously said I'm
getting arrested on Tuesday, which didn't happen
on that day, his supporters really didn't seem to
be activating the way he wanted them to. So let's
all hope cooler heads prevail as justice proceeds.
Let's hope this is the first of many indictments.
We're going to take a break. What a day. What a
day. The David Pakman Show is, of course, made
possible day in and day out by our members.
Membership is cheap, it's quick and it feels good.
You can sign up at join Pacman dot com and know
that unlike your cable subscription from which
four bucks a month go to Fox News, all but 2.9% of
every dollar which goes to just swiping the credit
cards and debit cards comes directly to us sign
up at join Packman dot com you can use the coupon
code at 24 starts now to get yourself a discount.